So, Vista is the RVM library that has been implemented on top of the Rio file
cache, and let's see how that works. The
semantics of RVM that is implemented in this
is exactly the same as what we saw in the previous lesson, namely LRVM. It is
just that the implementation takes advantage of the
fact that it is sitting on top of
a Rio file cache. So what we're going to
do in implementing RVM using the Rio file cache
is to map the data segment to the virtual
memory. Exactly similar to what was done in the
LRVM primitive. So, when we map the external data
segment to virtual memory, by definition now, this portion
of the memory becomes persistent because it is contained
in the file cache and the file cache survives
power failure because of the battery backup. And
therefore, now we have made this portion of
the virtual memory, that is mapped to the
data segment, persistent. So when we hit the begin
transaction call in the application, what we're going to
do is make a before image of the portion
of the virtual memory that we're going to modify
during this transaction. Remember that in the RVM library,
the set of operations that you do
to virtual memory between begin transaction and end
transaction. The user's intent is that those changes
are for persistent data structures. And the persistent
data structures that they want to modify, they
would execute a set range call to say
what portion of that address range needs to
persistent. So. What we do in this Vista,
which is an implementation of RVM is, at
the point of begin transaction, we're going to make
a before image, a copy, in-memory copy, of
the portion of the address space that we intend
to modify during this transaction. That will serve
as the undo log. Now, note that this is
also mapped to the file cache, so the undo log is mapped to the file cache and
therefore this undo log, is by definition, persistent
node. So the undo record that we create
in memory, we back it up on the file cache and therefore this undo log that
we have created is actually persistent. It'll survive
failures. So when the program is executing the
body of the transaction, it's doing normal program
rights to a portion of the virtual address space
where it has persistent data structures as well.
So when it does this normal program rights to
this virtual memory. The portion of the virtual memory
that is mapped to this external data segment is,
by definition, persistent and so these normal programs
rights actually get into the data segment, their being
persistent automatically because this portion of the virtual address
space is mapped to this data segment. Which is
in the file cache and therefore persistent because
of the battery backing. So all the changes
that we are making during the execution of
the body of the transaction code is actually getting
persisted in the original data segment. For which
this was an in-memory copy, but the in-memory copy
is actually sitting in file cache, which is
battery backed. Then we reach the end transaction in
the application code, and remember, in the end
transaction is when a change has had to
be committed. Well, you know what? The changes
are already committed because that is the semantic
of mapping the latest segment in virtual memory.
And because the file cache is persistent, all
the changes that we made to the virtual
memory during these normal program writes are actually reflected
in the data segment. So the end transaction
at commit point, you don't have to do
anything other than getting rid of this undo
log, because the transaction is committed and therefore you
can throw away this undo log and all
the changes are already in there by design, by
construction. Just as an aside, if you think
about LRV implementation, commit point is the point where
there is heavy lifting to be done. Because
in LRVM, at the commit point, the redo
log, which had been created by LRVM, to
reflect the changes to the persistent data structures in
memory, have to be forced to the disk.
But in Vista, which is implementation of RVM
on a persistent file cashe, no work needs
to be done at the point of end transaction
for commit because all the changes that the
application developer intended to be committed to the
data segment are already in there. And therefore,
at commit point, all that needs to be
done by Vista is to get rid of this undo log. On the other hand, if the
transaction aborts, in that case, what needs to be done is the undo record that
we created at the beginning of the transaction, the
before image, we are to take that and copy
it back into the portion of the virtual memory
that we modified, because that is a semantic of RBM.
That if the transaction aborts, we restore the virtual
memory back to it's original state before the beginning of
the transaction. So the before image that we saved
at the beginning of the transaction, we copy it back
into this portion of the virtual memory that
has been modified during this transaction. And once we
do that, we can throw away the undo log.
And when we restore the before image into the
virtual memory that we're also correcting whatever changes we
made to the data segment automatically. Because, remember that
this picture is just showing the virtual address space
of the process and this is really the physical
memory which is being used as a file cache battery backed and a portion of
the virtual address space is in this battery
pack file cache, rest of the address base
of the application, does not need persistence,
that can be a normal physical memory. Only
the portion of the application memory that has
persistence guarantees through the data segment needs to
be mapped to this portion of the physical memory
that is battery backed. So just to recap what happens
at end transaction, if it's a commit, no work
to be done except to get rid of the undo
record. All the changes to persistent data structures are
already in there in the data segment. On the other
hand, if it aborts, restore the old image back
into the virtual memory, I am back in business as
though these transaction never happened. The implication of
this Vista implementation, which is RVM on top of
Rio file cache, is that there is no disk IO at all. And there is no redo
log, because we directly writing into the data
segments All the external data segments that we define
in the initialization of the RVM library on
the disk, they become memory resident when you map
them into the virtual address space of the
application. So the external data segments become persistent because
of being brought into the file cache. And mapped
into the virtual memory space of the server application.